俺は映画オデッセイを見て
宇宙に憧れ　火星に憧れ
宇宙飛行士に憧れた
なんとかして宇宙飛行士になりたいと思った俺は
宇宙服を・・・手に入れた・・・
♪～
はい、というわけで
何とかしてガチモンの宇宙服を準備しました
僕はこれを使って実際に
宇宙服を着ると、どんな感じになるのか
宇宙に行った人たちの気持ちになってね・・・
着てみようと思います　ではいこう！
よし！
ついに俺もここまで来たか
やっぱりね...宇宙の大変さを知ってこそ、語れることってあると思うんだよ。
まず靴を履くね、靴。
こういうことっしょ？よしよしよし...
え、怖い、あ゛っ痛あ～！！
いきなり刺さったよ！！
えっ、硬っ！あ゛あ～！（笑）
えっ...
（笑い）
汚ねえよ
はあ～
やさしくして...わあっ
（後輩）前取れたし。　（はじめ）えっ
いい子だ。
肩やばい、肩。キツイなこれ...
めっちゃキツイ。
１つ言えるのは...
（笑い）
確かね、これ３０キロくらいなんですよ、恐らく。
ぎゃああ～
うう～
わああ～
はい！というわけで、無事出来ました～！
なんとか宇宙服を着れたんですけども、
実際に宇宙服を着るとどんな感じなのか、というのをね、ちょっと
身をもって体験できれば、と思っております。
では、いろいろちょっとやってみましょう。
えー、歩いても…
けっこう...重量が...
あの...
宇宙服着たままスマートフォンの操作ができるか
やってみようと思います
指が太いんで...これで操作しにくかったら最悪だなと思って。
ちょっと実際にやってみようと思います
階段をちょっと宇宙服で下りてみようと思います
体が太いので、
どれくらい大変なのかを、ちょっと実際にやってみようと思います。
わあ！やばい！
ついてきた！
どうなってる、どうなってる？
うわあっ！
意外と降りれるもんだね。
ペンで、実際に字を書いてみようと思います
（笑い）
宇宙服でいろいろやってみんですけども...とても、辛いものがありました。
でもここは重力のある空間なので、こんなことやってても正直意味がないんですよ。
実際に、ちょっと宇宙に行って飛んでる感じを体験しないと多分意味ないと思うんで、
ちょっと宇宙服で、空中ブランコに
挑戦してみようと思います。
では、行きましょう。
♪～
空中ブランコができる場所に来ました。
けっこう高いんですけども、
僕は宇宙服を着ているわけなんで、宇宙の気分をこのまま楽しめればいいなと思っております。
では実際に、宇宙を体感してみましょう。
行くぜ
♪～
まあひとまず...宇宙だけは体験しようと思っているので、
ちょっと空中ブランコやってみようと思います。
行ってきます。
では、行ってきます...宇宙の旅に...
♪～
行ってきます。
カンッ（金属音）
（お姉さん）本番行きます。レディー...ハイッ！
（インストラクター）今！足上げて、ひざ曲げて～
（インストラクター）もう一回いきましょう
♪～
（お姉さん）大きな拍手お願いします～
（拍手）
♪～
（男性の声）ハイッ
（男性）ちょっとタイミングずれたので、一回降りたいと思います～
遅かったですね...
♪～
（男性）ハイッ
（インストラクター）今足上げて、ひざ曲げて
（インストラクター）エビぞりして
♪～
よっしゃあ！
やったああ～！！
（拍手）
宇宙を...感じることができました...
はい！というわけで、いかがだったでしょうか？
空中ブランコ。あれね、タイミングが合わなきゃいけない、ちゃんと伸びなきゃダメなので、
すごい難しいんですよ。
上手くいってよかったです。
かなり練習しました。
はい、というわけで『オデッセイ』なんですけども、
宇宙の無重力の空間の中でのね、ああいうちょっとアクションちっくなシーンもあるので、
そちらも是非、楽しみにして観ていただけるとありがたいです。
本当にいい作品なので、ぜひ観てください。
果たしてワトニーは、火星で生き延びることができるのか？
そして、助かるのか？
『オデッセイ』、僕からも本当におススメの作品です。ぜひ見てください。
前の動画でも言ったんですけど、オデッセイ、こういうねオデッセイプラント...植物が今もらえるみたいです。
けっこう大きくなったかな？ニョキっと生えてきたんですけども、
もし火星に取り残されることがあったら、こういう植物を育てる力はとても大切です。
よかったら、これ育ててみたいなって思った人
下の動画説明欄から応募できますので
よかったら、このオデッセイプラント育ててみてください。
タダでもらえるみたいです
じゃあな！
♪～